[موسيقى]
اخبار زلزالي تركيا وسوريا وتداعياته
بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم
ارتفاع عدد ضحايا زلزالك كهرمان في تركيا
الى اكثر من 16000 قتيل ونحو 64 الف مصاب
السلطات تعلن انتهاء اعمال الانقاذ في
منطقتي شانلي اورفا وكيليس وتقول ان
البلاد تعرضت نحو 1300 هز ارتداديه حتى
الان
اردوغان يقول ان مؤسسات الدوله كافه تبذل
قصار جهدها لانقاذ المتضررين من الزلازل
مضيفا خلال زياره تفقديه لمدينه غازي
عنتاب ان بناء منازل للمتضررين هو اولويه
الدوله ومشيرا الى ان هناك من يحاول
استغلال الماساه للحصول على مكاسب سياسيه
وفي سوريا ارتفاع عدد ضحايا الزلزال الى
اكثر من 3000 قتيل ودفاع مدني في مناطق
الشمال السوري يحذر من ان الوقت اخذ في
النفاذ مع استمرار وجود مئات العائلات
عالقه تحت الانقاض في الاثناء تواجه اكثر
من 300 عائله الخطر بسبب تصدع سد التلول
على نهر العاصي برفي ادلب في اعقاب
الزلزال
قافله اولى من المساعدات تدخل الى مناطق
المنكوبين شمال غربي سوريا من معبر باب
الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا المبعوث الدولي
الى سوريا يطالب بعدم تسييس الاستجابه
الطارئه لضحايا الزلزال والاتحاد الاوروبي
يدعو لتامين وصول المساعدات للمحتاجين
اينما كانوا
الى اللقاء